My name is Mirsina Aghdam, CEO of EDGE.
Earthwise Dynamics Geo Environs.
Europe needs more secure and responsible
access to critical minerals.
Identifying and prioritising promising areas
for exploration remains slow, fragmented and expensive.
At EDGE, we are developing TerraLens AI:
an evidence-led system bringing together
drone, LiDAR, satellite, hyperspectral and geological data.
The aim is practical: clearer, traceable evidence
for exploration teams assessing potential targets.
With support from ESA BIC Ireland, we are progressing
terrestrial development and preparing European field validation.
This work provides the foundation for AstraLens:
EDGE’s future roadmap for space-enabled mineral intelligence.
EDGE combines geoengineering and AI automation
with Earth observation for informed decisions.